[Music]  halloween i think was i think a lot of  people had fun yeah people here had fun  uh but i got to tell you i personally  i'm glad it's over i'm glad it's so good  and i'll tell you why yesterday andy  was hiding around the office  and then jumping out and scaring people  it's the best no you're a grown man i  know but it's great yeah yeah so he  hides he jumps out and scares people he  does it all day  worst of all this year i think it's the  first year he taped it yeah he taped it  isn't this right andy idea  and i man i got la bomba fantastic  this is the one i want to show watch  this  don't be scared  now naturally yeah some of you are  probably wondering  how could la bamba be in the band  tonight  if andy murdered him yesterday  there's a very simple explanation take a  look  [Applause]  why am i wet  that's right  he's made of foam  [Applause]  [Music]  that is such a stupid idea